Gregg G asks what is the ratio of
studying and socialize like it altered
now I think that the good thing about
Oxford is although you do work hard you
also do party quite hard as well if you
if you went to that um I think it's
quite good because you're so close to
all your friends like as soon as you're
at the library you're socializing and
like the bar is right in college this
there's not any of sort of annoying
intermediate time it's all very you
don't need to worry too much I think
I've never found it an issue that I
didn't have another sort of sexual yeah
the accommodation in first year at st.
Peter's and of most colleges is catered
so you eat all your meals at home which
in itself is a in the threat and
freshers week is a incredibly useful way
to just to get to know he want to make
friends because you're almost forced
into socializing by the act of going to
a halt and eating a mess when it's kind
of like so going out for meal with your
friends but nearly like every single day
it's really really nice obviously quite
as amazing as that and you have Falls
and things
yeah which are good where you get to
where you're going it's like Harry
Potter yeah yeah the formal being like
essentially like a three-course meal
which is actually quite cheap so the
won't say pieces hell yeah seven pounds
will say and he's really nice and people
do when they want a girl by evening or
they want to have the so based on this
birthday we've deemed ones as well as
you can yeah charity Harry Potter one
sort of Halloween Halloween night young
tastic yeah a Christmas one's really
good as well
ultimately it's what you make of it till
the work-life balance more into the work
side of things and you can but you will
never be at a loss for things to do you
always be busy and there's always loads
of stuff going on so you definitely
won't be bored yes the good thing you
have the freedom to do kind of what you
want oh there's so many things on offer
to do knocks that I've kind of found
that most people here take a lot of
advantage of them and are the kind of
good thing is people when they're not
working they
they've got so much opportunity to
socialize almost instantly that it's
yeah that's kind of one of the special
things about being the college that he
did struggling and there's also from
good sort of like groups but you knew
I'd sort of societies and things which
are really good ways of meeting other
people and you can earn like also like a
lot of the support that's really good
sports facilities it's really good stuff
facilities to do pretty much whatever
you want in your spare time as long as
you make the most of your spare time
then you don't feel far done by that
you're working quite a bit yeah and that
the freshers fair and when you arrive
there's about there's a freshers fair of
about 300 societies or so really random
stuff and I've got involved in things
I'd never thought I'd get involved in
like I know really like Scottish dancing
and kind of wooden couldn't really
imagine myself doing that before
University Cloquet as well let's go
screams bad bad image place so so much
fun the angles have never be more never
have never played it before here yeah no
I mean it's an opportunity you have to
be really pressed about it yeah so
there's loads of stuff to do
so the next question says in terms of
settling into life at Oxford during your
first few weeks that when making friends
and meeting new people difficult and
what was the change in workload like
from a level and how did you manage it
so I found that within like two days I'd
already met so many people and made
quite a lot of friends and speaking to
my other friends from home during that
freshers week as well it sounded like
I've met a whole lots lots more people
and it's having more fun with lots of
different people than they were because
I don't know in other unis when you have
the flat you kind of meet a group of
people and they tend to sort of click
together and stay in those groups
whereas here because we've got the
college atmosphere in like Ryan said
about poles and stuff you're in you're
in a big group but it's still small
enough to get to there everybody so I
just I yeah you get to know so many
names and faces it's found it much much
easier than I thought it would be mainly
because opposites special in this
there are so many different categories
and friendship groups you can get
involved in very quickly so obviously
you've just got people you know in
college you've got people who are going
to be in your accommodation of it
everyone or there's it's okay so it's
either there's two main accommodation
blocks Matthews and a new block and
people develop attachments done very
quickly there's then of course there's
your subject group you get to know your
subject very quickly you have a meal
with them and first week and meet all
your tutors and staff say and then
there's obviously people you're just
going to meet in the bar and when the
the best thing about freshers week of
obviously is that there's a freshman
suite committee and they organize lots
and lots of different events varying
nature to get people involved in talking
to each other and stuff so it's very I
find it very very easy again the thing
about meeting a hole all the time I
obviously didn't meet that many people
on the first day but on the first
morning had to come down and get
breakfast and there's such a nice
atmosphere in college anyway that you
sit back next to people and they you
know especially for the in freshers week
and throughout the first term people
actively trying to engage in
conversation the second or third years
because they went through that same for
any other themselves have a good life so
I'm yeah I found it they know they're
surprisingly easy I thought that's great
and because again go about the idea of
forming not forming cliques that works
well in college because we've got so
many people people here from all sorts
of backgrounds in different countries
you find yourself in a very diverse with
a diverse bunch of friends very very
quickly which is fantastic
another thing the other thing to make
the point to make here is that everyone
is in exactly the same situation as you
so it's not like like because I found
when I went to sixth form from my high
school and everyone I saw already going
in friendship groups whereas to uni no
one knows anyone and everyone is just
once and make friends with everyone else
and everyone seems to be really lovely
as well but the other thing the work
balance thing I didn't find it too much
of an issue like usually do you're
basically just doing a lot of one
subject and it's just less less sort of
lots of subjects and more just all on
one subject it's like I haven't found
the work days any particularly different
the workdays I do before it's just more
focused on one no particularly for some
of the humanities subjects if you spent
the same amount of time on your subject
that you spent as in the school day then
you wouldn't have any trouble at all
obviously some subjects are more
demanding than others but in general
it's not too drastic break part of the
reason the admissions process has to be
so big of us is that obviously studying
Oxford is can be taxing at times and the
University and tutors need to know that
you know you'll be able to do it so if
you take up a place and you're right
here that I wouldn't worry about it also
you've got your in freshers week you'll
meet people in your subject from the
years above so they can talk to you if
you have any sort concerns
you